if you had to boil down the experience
to one word what is your word for
all-stars fire that's your word but I
think it counts as one yeah a beer or a
check for that well hi Shay hi Bob I
want to I want to start just by talking
about this moment in time we're in and
you have amazingly stepped up to use
your platform to shine light on this
moment and I just want to talk about
next steps where do we go from here
I think next steps and what's important
is to continue to amplify the voices of
black people especially while we're and
on Pride Month black trans people hmm
because when we really want to talk
about movements and making advances
forward and we want to talk about
equality on the thing that's most
important is thinking about the most
vulnerable members of our community and
finding ways to make life easier and
safer for them how can we find
legislation to make this world more
inclusive for them and then from there
once we have these conversations then it
is up to us to hold white people and
people of privilege accountable for
taking the necessary steps to help
eradicate systemic racism and oppression
the work is now being placed over into
the hands of white people because if
we're going to undo racism then we need
to do it from the root and we have to
look at where it started for them in
white supremacy is something that has
been created by white people so if we're
going to dismantle it then we need to
talk to the creator what is it meant to
you to see the community of drag race
really step up in this moment to help
educate and spread this message I mean
we've always been girls that have really
been outspoken about racial injustice
that's what I think right now in this
moment
time the microphone has been turned
around to the people that have not been
listened to in the past and now we have
to really take this opportunity as
people with platforms to come together
on a united front to help educate the
masses on how we can break down these
barriers you touched briefly on this but
I think it does mean something that this
is intersecting with the month of pride
can you speak to that a little bit about
how this is all coming to a head as
Pride Month is starting um yes I think
it's actually very interesting that this
is all coming to a head during Pride
Month specifically because Pride Month
came about because we were protesting
police brutality and when we think about
the community leaders at that time back
in 1969 the people that were really out
there organizing on behalf of the people
were transformed in a color like Marcia
P Johnson so if we're going to go
forward in this current political
climate that were in I think it's really
important to acknowledge that before we
were even here it was black and brown
trans people that were really
championing for us to have the ability
to march in the streets and enhance
celebrating our love we just have to
continue on in this path yes this has
been a crazy and really intense two
weeks but we're talking about over 400
years systemic oppression and though we
made some strides this past few weeks
we still have a very long way to go and
I want to be encouraging for our allies
but I also want to challenge white
people to understand like yeah you've
done some things and spoken to some
friends you know that's too weak so we
have to continue the momentum we have to
keep going we still have to you know
stay in this fight and continue on for
equality because that's the only way
that it's going to happen the way that
one thing that my mom always did growing
up is the squeaky wheel gets the like a
hundred percent all right thank you for
all of that and thank you for all the
work you're doing that you continue to
do let's take a pivot now to talk
you're all stars 5 journey the
revolution starts now it is so exciting
to have you back on TV because you were
such an all-star on your original season
what did you feel like you had left to
prove coming back this time I feel like
the only thing I had left to prove is to
carry off a successful lip-sync that's
right doubled last time but coming in
this time I really wanted to make this
journey one about personal growth when I
came and I had decided that the
competition that I was going to say was
going to be against myself and against
my own inner saboteur also helped me to
overcome a lot of just like personal
issues I was dealing with after season 9
you know I it was a really big ego blow
I had to go through an entire eat so
death you know in order to come back and
rebuild myself and be in a position
where I really could say that I could
really handle the responsibility and the
privilege that comes along with being in
the whole thing do you have any PTSD
anytime you see rose petals now um no I
love rose petals I mean Valentine's Day
is always a little bit confronting
because everywhere but besides that no
me and rose petals were all very did you
feel pressure of like trying to come up
with a stunt that could you know your
answer to that I feel like the others
definitely like all this pressure to you
know be like oh you know what's your
answer to that I think again I I had to
focus on what was going to be best for
me and what was going to uplift me in
this experience but
I guess you're just gonna have to
continue to see what I pull out this
season I don't want to get too much away
when you saw the full lineup there did
anybody give you pause like oh this
[ __ ] is here I have to step it up no
cuz I already came ready to be fully
steps up you know there nobody that I
didn't already be like okay do I think I
can honestly honestly truly beat her and
we'll discuss the fate you are coming
into our TV screens a fan favorite when
I was talking to all the season 12
Queens 9 out of the 12 said you are
their choice to win this season does
that add any pressure um no because at
the end of the day it's all said and
done I've done absolutely everything
that I could do and at the end of the
day I'm really proud of what I did and I
just hope that my performance on all
starts I've lived up to the expectations
of the fans and of all the people that
support me and if for any reason I do
disappoint people that I'm gonna say you
do it damn it that's the answer now you
came in thinking the show is gonna be
one thing and they flip the script and
change some of the rules up on you the
top all-star of the week will lip-synch
for her legacy but she'll be competing
against
a secret lip-sync how do you really feel
about the lipstick assassin twist I knew
there was gonna be a twist look because
you're saying we hide all stars two
three or four with the format of the
double winners and I just said to myself
like there's no way we're going to do
all stars five and they're not gonna
find some way to switch this up because
like at this point the girls feel like
they know what you expect and that
doesn't make for an interesting
competition so I already kind of had my
guard up when I came in because I was
like I know we're all there's always
some shenanigans but when they revealed
the lipstick assassin plotline I
realized I was like hey this was a great
opportunity to redeem myself as a
lip-sync assassin you know because that
means that I got to be able to take on
someone who is notably an amazing lip
syncher and once RuPaul reveals that the
cash prize would be rolling over if the
girl didn't beat so let's take us out
then that was when I was all like now
this is the game that I won't play it's
also getting your bank account public
once hello hello my bank account was
ringing at that leg okay I really loved
the statement you put out last week
about your thoughts of the state of the
world before the premiere and in talking
to your sisters it sounds like some of
the conversations you guys had in the
workroom you know behind the scenes of
the competition are going to speak
actually to this moment in time now
little did you know yeah what can you
tell me about that I think about my
Angelou quote where she says people may
not remember what she said or what you
did but they'll always remember how you
made them feel
and there were so many people involved
in this process that were committed to
uplifting one another and making sure
that everyone did their best because
everybody understood the importance of
this show and that it provides hope to a
lot of people around the world and I
think now more than ever it's really
important to me
to communicate and carry that message so
I'm really hoping that it really does
show through on camera of the way that
we felt off you
[Music]